Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. There is an inscription written over these men who were buried where they fell, and over those who died before the others went away, dismissed by Leonidas. It reads as follows. Here four thousand men from the Peloponnese once fought three million. That inscription is for them all, but the Spartans have their own. Go tell the
感谢收听《历史其余部分》。如果您想收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告收听、提前解锁节目系列以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。在这些阵亡者的墓碑上，以及在列奥尼达遣散其他人之前不幸牺牲的人的墓碑上，刻着这样一段铭文。内容如下：伯罗奔尼撒的四千勇士，曾在此地与三百万大军浴血奋战。这块铭文属于他们所有人，但斯巴达人有他们自己的铭文。去告诉
Spartans, thou who passest by, that here, obedient to their laws, we lie. So wrote Herodotus, the father of history, looking back on the Spartans who died at the Battle of Thermopylae. Tom, Tom Holland, Thermopylae is one of the two great engagements in the greco-persian wars the the wars that in some ways are at the very foundation of history itself so um tell us why are we doing this subject apart from the fact that it's a brilliant subject it is a brilliant subject uh i have to say i mean basically it's it's the subject that got me into history as a child so maybe come to that in a minute but but the reason we're doing um specifically thermopylae and salamis which are the two great battles for in 480 bc is that this is the 2500th anniversary so this episode will be going out at approximately
斯巴达人，路过的人啊，遵从他们的法律，我们长眠于此。历史之父希罗多德这样写道，回首着在温泉关战役中牺牲的斯巴达人。汤姆，汤姆·霍兰，温泉关是希波战争中两场伟大的战役之一，这场战争在某些方面可以说是历史本身的基石。所以，嗯，告诉我们，我们为什么要讲这个主题？除了它是一个极其精彩的主题之外——它确实是一个极其精彩的主题。呃，我得说，基本上正是这个主题让我从小就迷上了历史，所以也许我们待会儿会谈到这一点。但是，我们之所以专门讲温泉关和萨拉米斯——这两场发生在公元前480年的伟大战役——是因为今年是2500周年。所以这集节目播出的时间，大约正值
the day on which 2500 years ago, the Persian battle fleet was defeated in the Straits of Salamis, thereby perhaps radically changing the course of history. I mean, we might come onto a discussion about that later. I thought we would. But as you said, also, it is in a way kind of the foundation of history because this story about how the greeks confronted the persians and defeated them became the theme for
2500年前的这一天，波斯舰队在萨拉米斯海峡战败，从而可能彻底改变了历史的进程。我的意思是，我们稍后可能会讨论这一点。我本来就打算这么做。但正如你所说，从某种意义上讲，这也是历史的基石，因为关于希腊人如何对抗波斯人并战胜他们的这个故事，成为了
the first great work of history herodotus and i'm very grateful that you um you cited him but you didn't use my translation i didn't use your translation do you know why i i just couldn't find it in time to be be honest. Oh, well. Even as I was reading it, I felt a little bit... You knew I'd be cross. I thought you'd be cross, but I thought that would add a piquancy to the episode. Yes, it does. It does. It's driven me into an absolute fury. Now, of course, you have only recently been associating with the Persian, because you are coming to this. I mean, one reason I wanted to puncture your sort of bubble of immense pride,
第一部伟大的历史著作的主题——希罗多德的作品。我很感激你提到了他，但你没有用我的翻译。我没有用你的翻译？你知道为什么吗？老实说，我只是当时没找到。哦，好吧。甚至当我读它的时候，我就觉得有点……你知道我会生气的。我以为你会生气，但我觉得这会给这集节目增添一点情趣。是的，确实增添了。这把我气得火冒三丈。现在，当然，你最近才开始跟波斯人混在一起，因为你要来谈这个。我的意思是，我想戳破你那种极度自豪的泡沫的一个原因——
not that you have a bubble of immense pride, but if you did, I would want to puncture it, is that you've been basking in the adulation of fans of The Rest Is History, haven't you? Because you've just, only a couple of days ago, you did the live show about top 10 mistresses with top Persian, Ali Ansari. We did. And I think, I'm not entirely sure of the logistics of it.
倒不是说你真的有什么极度自豪的泡沫，但如果你有的话，我很想戳破它——是因为你最近一直沐浴在《历史其余部分》粉丝们的奉承中，不是吗？因为就在几天前，你还和波斯通阿里·安萨里一起做了关于“十大情妇”的现场演出。我们确实做了。而且我想，我不太确定其中的后勤安排。
And this is all very complicated, isn't it? We record these episodes before they then go out, obviously. But I think that the top 10 mistresses, which was the subject of our live show at the London Podcast Festival, will have gone out before this episode goes out. So perhaps people may have heard it. But Dominic, you were much missed.
这一切都很复杂，对吧？显然，我们是在这些节目播出之前进行录制的。但我认为，作为我们在伦敦播客节上现场演出主题的“十大情妇”，应该会在本期节目播出之前就已经上线了。所以也许大家已经听过了。不过，多米尼克，大家都很想念你。
Well, I don't believe that at all. No, really know really I mean it was lovely to do it with Ali who was absolutely brilliant um as he was in in the Persia episode I mean he got in I mean if people have heard the episode but he got in an absolutely terrible Persian mistress I mean yeah she was called the nightingale but then he went on to say she was actually called the parrot and i waited to hear what this amazing iranian mistress had done and she'd done absolutely nothing oh no i mean if i was gonna have a persian mistress my expectations would be very high i was very disappointed in that but having said that everything else about persia obviously is brilliant yes um you know my thesis and one that ali shares that basically everything comes from persia um and that is i think what makes the story of the persian invasion of greece so brilliant and it's something that i didn't realize really when i got obsessed by it as a child where i was all over the greeks it was
嗯，我可一点也不信。不，真的，真的，我的意思是，和阿里一起做这期节目真是太棒了，他绝对才华横溢，就像他在波斯那一集里一样。我的意思是，如果大家听过那一集的话就会知道，他讲了一个绝对糟糕透顶的波斯情妇。我的意思是，对，她被称为夜莺，但接着他又说她其实叫鹦鹉。我等着听这位了不起的伊朗情妇做了什么惊天动地的事，结果她什么也没做。哦，不！我的意思是，如果我要找一个波斯情妇，我的期望值会非常高，我对那个节目真的很失望。话虽如此，关于波斯的一切显然都非常精彩。是的，你知道我的观点，也是阿里赞同的观点：基本上一切都源自波斯。我认为，正是这一点，让波斯入侵希腊的故事变得如此精彩。这也是我小时候着迷于此时尚未真正意识到的一点——那时我完全心仪希腊，
completely greece it was it was Athens it was Sparta absolutely on their side but I now with the wisdom of many my many decades my wisdom of the years I now appreciate that that we owe just as much to Persia as we do okay and that's what makes this such a seismic so let's put this into context for listeners who who who don't share your childhood childlike childhood enthusiasm so we're in the fifth century bc is that right and that's right isn't it tom you're just looking yes yes and persia is top nation i mean persia is by far the most important rich sophisticated civilization in the eurasian world i guess well i mean putting china on one side and greece is nothing am i right i mean greece is just a
完全是希腊，那是雅典，那是斯巴达，我绝对站在他们那边。但现在，凭借我几十年的智慧，凭借我岁月的智慧，我开始认识到，我们对波斯的亏欠丝毫不亚于对希腊的亏欠，好吧。正是这一点，让它变得如此震撼人心。那么，让我们把这放在历史背景中，为那些没有你那种童年般热情听众们解释一下：我们身处公元前五世纪，对吧？没错，不是吗，汤姆？你正看着我呢——是的，是的。波斯是头号大国。我的意思是，波斯是欧亚大陆上迄今为止最重要、最富裕、最sophisticated（成熟精致）的文明，我是说，把中国放在一边的话。而希腊什么都不是，我说的对吗？希腊只是一群
collection of of kind of so pretty obscure little city states so persia is um i mean it's not just the greatest power on the face of the planet. It's the greatest power that has ever existed. The scale of its empire is unprecedented. And it goes from the shores of the Aegean right the way up. Well, you know, we talked about this in our Afghanistan episode. It goes all the way up beyond Afghanistan into kind of Central Asia to the Indus. It's rich. It's teeming with manpower.
某种相当默默无闻的小城邦。所以波斯，我的意思是，它不仅是地球上面积最大、实力最强的力量，而且是历史上存在过的最伟大的力量。其帝国的规模是空前绝后的。它的疆域从爱琴海之滨一直延伸出去。好吧，正如我们在阿富汗那一集里讨论过的，它一直延伸到阿富汗以外的中亚，直抵印度河流域。它物产丰饶，人力资源极其充沛。
It commands the most sophisticated, the most ancient civilizations in the world, Egypt, Babylon, absolutely a stupefying power. And compared to that, absolutely, the Greeks are nothing. And when i wrote potion fire which um i'm shamelessly going to plug no you should my book on this it is the popular history on this but it but it's kind of i hate you know you have to write a blurb and i wrote person fire in the backdrop to the invasion of afghanistan and the iraq war and And during the Iraq war, there was a lot of talk from American
它统治着世界上最精致、最古老的文明——埃及、巴比伦，绝对是一个令人瞠目结舌的超级大国。相比之下，希腊真的什么都不是。当我写《波斯之火》时——我无耻地要在这里推销一下这本书——不，你理应这么做——我的那本关于此事的书，它是关于这方面的通俗历史。但它有点……我讨厌，你知道的，你得写一段内容简介。我写《波斯之火》时的背景是美国入侵阿富汗和伊拉克战争。在伊拉克战争期间，美国的
neocons about how America was the heir of Athens. It was a democracy. And that the war in Iraq was a war for democracy. And so therefore, in a sense, they were the Athenians. But it struck me then, and it struck me very strongly over the past month with the kind of withdrawal from from Afghanistan that actually, in a sense, America is, you know, in a sense of kind of global mission. It's its superpower status, its desire to bring order to a kind of rugged terrorist ridden backwater is actually America, is actually Persia. And so the blurb that I wrote for Persian Fire, in the fifth century BC, a global superpower was determined to bring truth and order to what it regarded as two terrorist states. The superpower was Persia, incomparably rich in ambition, golden men. The terrorist states were Athens and Sparta, eccentric cities in a poor and mountainous backwater Greece and so I think that that does kind of brilliantly scramble I should say brilliantly I'm being modest but the the idea of of um that that we in the west can trace our origins to
新保守主义者有很多言论，认为美国是雅典的继承者。它是一个民主国家。伊拉克战争是一场为了民主的战争。因此，从某种意义上说，他们就是雅典人。但当时我就有这种感觉，并且在过去一个月里随着从阿富汗撤军，这种感觉变得极其强烈：事实上，从某种意义上说，美国的全球使命、它的超级大国地位、它渴望给一个崎岖不平、恐怖主义肆虐的落后地区带来秩序的愿望，其实美国就是波斯。因此，我为《波斯之火》写的内容简介是这样的：在公元前五世纪，一个全球超级大国决心给它视作两个恐怖主义国家的地区带去真理与秩序。这个超级大国就是波斯，拥有无可比拟的雄厚野心和黄金铸就的人民。恐怖主义国家则是雅典和斯巴达，它们是贫瘠多山的希腊后方中几个古怪的城市。所以我认为这确实巧妙地颠覆了——我该说巧妙吗？我太谦虚了——这种观点：我们西方人不仅可以将我们的起源追溯到
Persia as well as to Greece I think is a great way to kind of scramble the default assumption that we in the west are just they are kind of you know things well some there are two there are two aspects to that aren't there to that sort of very helena centric um portrait that we have one is if you ever look at a map of the persian wars greece is kind of central and most of the persian empire is off stage so it's just this sort of shadowy eastern power and greece is the center of the world but obviously that's not how people are how most people in the kind of eurasian landmass thought of greece they thought of greece as very peripheral and persia is central of these great cities well i guess so but i mean your mental g so. But I mean, your mental Greece. Well, I mean, but your mental world is defined by Persia rather than by Greece. Right. For most people at the time, for most, let's say, educated people. the first work of history ever written so so this is you know he's blazing the path here
希腊，也可以追溯到波斯。我认为这是打破那种默认假设的绝佳方式——我们西方人只是……好吧，这里有两个方面，不是吗？关于那种非常以海伦为中心的画像，其中一个方面是：如果你看过任何一张希腊波斯战争的地图，希腊似乎总是居于中心，而绝大部分波斯帝国都在舞台之外。所以它只是一种若隐若现的东方力量，而希腊则是世界的中心。但很显然，当时欧亚大陆上的大多数人并不是这样看待希腊的。他们认为希腊非常边缘化，而波斯才是这些伟大城市的中心。嗯，我想是的，但我的意思是，你的精神世界……好吧，我的意思是，但你的精神世界是由波斯而不是希腊定义的。没错。对于当时的绝大多数人来说，对于绝大多数，比如说，受过教育的人来说，
and he is writing about a Persian king called Cambyses who's the son of Cyrus the great who is the the kind of the the founder of the Persian empire eulogized by the Persians but also by the Greeks by the Jews I mean he's kind of you know he's hailed as the messiah in um in the book of isaiah and cambyses has invaded egypt and there supposedly he goes mad and herodotus draws this information from the egyptian piece it's it's it's probably propaganda but this is what he reports and he says one of the markers for why cambyses is mad is that he laughs at the egyptian gods for kind of having animal heads and the Egyptians for worshipping bulls and things like that. And Rodgers says this is insane because everybody thinks that their customs and their habits are the best and everybody thinks that their, you know,
这是有史以来第一部被撰写的历史著作。所以，看吧，他在这里开辟了道路。
their lands are the best. And as evidence for this, he tells a story about Darius the Great, who succeeds Cambyses and who is the king who sends the expedition to attack athens that gets defeated at marathon so in a sense the great enemy of the greeks but in this story he he is put center position and herodotus tells a story that deriah summons a greek and an indian and the greeks when their parents die burn them and the indians when their parents die her burn them. And the Indians, when their parents die, Herodotus reports, eat them. That's really not true. It's not true. But for the purposes of the story, let's say it is.
他们的土地是最好的。为了证明这一点，他讲了一个关于大流士大帝的故事。大流士是大流士继承了冈比西斯的王位，他也是派遣远征军进攻雅典、并在马拉松战役中被击败的国王。所以从某种意义上说，他是希腊人的死敌。但在个故事中，他被置于核心地位。希罗多德讲了一个故事：大流士召集了一个希腊人和一个印度人。希腊人死后会火化他们的父母，而印度人死后会……会火化他们。而印度人，当他们的父母去世时，希罗多德报道说，他们会吃掉父母。这其实并不是真的。这不是真的。但为了故事的需要，我们姑且这么认为吧。
And Darius says to the Greek, how much would I have to pay you to eat your parent? And the Greek goes, oh, I'd never do that. And to the Indian, he says, how much would I have to pay you to burn your parent? And the Indian is equally disgusted and revolted by the very idea. And Herodotus says, this proves what Pindar, the great poet, said, that custom is king, that everybody thinks his land is the best.
大流士对希腊人说：“我要付给你多少钱，你才肯吃掉你的父母？”希腊人说：“哦，我绝不会那样做。”他又对印度人说：“我要付给你多少钱，你才肯火化你的父母？”印度人对这个想法感到同样的厌恶和反感。希罗多德说，这证明了伟大诗人品达所说的话：习俗是君王，每个人都认为自己的土地是最好的。
But the thing that's fascinating about that is that Herodotus is actually situating Darius at the centre. Herodotus, a Greek, is looking at the world through Persian eyes yeah and I think that that is kind of reflective of the way that even a Greek could recognise that the Persians were kind of central in a way they wouldn't they wouldn't have done it the other way around a Persian writer wouldn't have looked through Greek eyes that person would never have done that the Persians were convinced that Persia was best and that um you know it stood at the center of the world of course the greeks said the same the greeks had this story that that zeus set two eight two two eagles flying from different corners of
但关于这一点，最迷人的是，希罗多德实际上把大流士放在了中心。希罗多德，一个希腊人，正通过波斯人的眼睛看待世界。是的，我认为这反映了这样一种方式：甚至连希腊人也能认识到，波斯人在某种程度上占据着核心地位，而他们反过来则不会这么做。一个波斯作家绝不会通过希腊人的眼睛来看待世界，波斯人绝不会那样做。波斯人坚信波斯是最好的，并且……你知道的，它屹立于世界的中心。当然，希腊人也这么说。希腊人流传着这样一个故事：宙斯让两只老鹰从世界的不同角落起飞，
the world and that they met over delphi so delphi is the center of the world for the greeks but i think it's possible for someone like herodotus who is who is born on the the the what's now the turkish side of the aegean from halicarnassicarnassus, is he? That's right, yes, which is now Bodrum, the great yachting capital, the great yachting centre. You could go and wear your yachting shoes there, Tom, like the Kaiser. Yes, I could. Yes, make sure I got the right ones. So he's born, I mean, he's a subject of the Persian king.
它们在德尔斐上空相遇。所以对于希腊人来说，德尔斐就是世界的中心。但我认为，对于像希罗多德这样的人来说——他出生在爱琴海现在土耳其那一侧的哈利卡纳苏斯，对吧？没错，是的。也就是现在的博德鲁姆，那个伟大的游艇之都，伟大的游艇中心。汤姆，你可以去那里穿上你的游艇鞋，就像德皇威廉二世那样。是的，我可以。是的，确保我穿对了鞋。所以他出生时，我的意思是，他是波斯国王的臣民。
So he kind of has, you know, foots in both worlds. Foots? Yeah, feet. He has a foot in both worlds. Well, Herodotus, okay, so Herodotus, that raises the other thing
所以他某种程度上……双脚踏在两个世界。双脚？对，双脚。他双脚踏在两个世界。好吧，希罗多德，好吧，希罗多德，这就引出了我要谈的另一件事，
I was going to talk about, which is that everything we are going to talk about, about Thermopylae and Salamis and the Persian Wars, everything comes from Greek sources, doesn't it?
那就是我们要谈的一切——关于温泉关、萨拉米斯以及希腊波斯战争——一切都来源于希腊人的记载，对吧？
I mean, we don't, am I right in thinking there are no real Persian, certainly no narrative Persian accounts of these events? Not a single mention of them
我的意思是，我的理解没错吧？没有任何真正的波斯人记载，当然也没有波斯人关于这些事件的叙事性记载？没有哪怕一丝一毫来自波斯人的提及。
from the Persians they do not mention them at all now maybe we'll come back to this but worth raising now this is obviously seismic for the Greeks but do the Persians even notice it's happened it's a moot point I mean it's indisputably a defeat, but obviously, unlike us, there aren't journalists, there aren't kind of cameramen, there aren't people on Twitter recording the humiliation. So the Persian king is able to kind of present it, I does seem to record how the Persians presented what had happened. So the two great battles in 480 when Xerxes, the Persian king, leads this invasion. There's the Battle of Thermopylae where the spartans hold the hot gates hold the passes but it gets turned and lenny does the the king gets killed and then the persians move down they occupy athens they burn it before being defeated at salamis and according to daio
他们根本没有提到过这些。现在，也许我们会回到这一点，但值得一提的是：这对希腊人来说显然是震撼人心的，但波斯人甚至注意到它发生了吗？这是一个有争议的问题。我的意思是，这无疑是一场战役的失利，但显然，与我们不同，当时没有记者，没有摄像机，没有人在推特上记录这种耻辱。所以波斯国王能够以某种方式……我的确似乎记录了波斯人是如何陈述所发生的事情的。因此，当波斯国王薛西斯在公元前480年率领这次入侵时，发生了两场大战。一场是温泉关之战，斯巴达人坚守热门关隘，坚守关卡，但防线被迂回包抄，国王列奥尼达被杀。然后波斯人长驱直入，占领了雅典，并将其付之一炬，随后在萨拉米斯战败。根据狄奥多罗斯的说法，
this is i mean he he says during his expedition to greece xerxes achieved victory over the spartans at thermopylae and killed King Leonidas there. Then he took and laid waste Athens, of which he sold into slavery all the inhabitants who had not succeeded in escaping. And after these successes, he imposed tribute on the Greeks and returned to Asia. Well, that sounds very much like a Persian victory. Yes. So I'm sure that that is how it would have been presented. And probably that is a kind of refracted echo of the original Persian propaganda, which hasn't survived. It's kind of rippling down through the centuries to be recorded by this Greek historian who, you know, he's very open to kind of Persian knowledge and influences.
我的意思是，他说：在远征希腊期间，薛西斯在温泉关战役中战胜了斯巴达人，并在那里杀死了列奥尼达国王。接着他攻占并荒废了雅典，将所有未能成功逃脱的居民变卖为奴。在取得这些胜利之后，他向希腊人征收贡赋，随后返回了亚洲。听起来这非常像是一场波斯人的伟大胜利。是的。所以我确信，当时他们就是这样描述这场战役的。这很可能是最初那些未能流传下来的波斯官方宣传的一缕折射回响，它穿过几个世纪的涟漪，被这位希腊历史学家记录了下来——他本人对波斯的知识和影响非常持开放态度。
But no, there are no Persian reports, really. And the reason for that is that the Persians essentially see themselves as having brought about the end of history. Okay. Everything's perfect. The Persians have conquered the world. And the thing about the Persians and the reason why there are, in a sense, we in the West are its heirs as well as the heirs of Athens, is that the Persians are the first people to moralize the idea of empire i think we talked about this in our episode on empire that they they see the world as divided into into to truth and the lie into light and into darkness um and inevitably they cast their own rulers as light and truth and they cast all those who
但没有，确实没有波斯方面的报告。究其原因，是因为波斯人本质上认为自己已经带来了历史的终结。好吧。一切都很完美。波斯人已经征服了世界。关于波斯人，以及为什么从某种意义上说我们西方人既是雅典的继承者、也是波斯帝国的继承者的原因在于：波斯人是第一批将帝国概念道德化的人。我想我们在关于帝国的节目里讨论过这一点：他们将世界划分为真理与谎言、光明与黑暗，
oppose them as as darkness and falsehood and that And that means that essentially there is no need to describe what they're doing because everything is perfect. They have brought about the absolute essence of everything that human civilization could be. And so therefore, what is there to write about? Well, that's not a great place to be a historian. No, it's a terrible place. To the degree that when you look at the kind of incredible portrayals of the Persian kings, Darius or Xerxes or whatever, it's often impossible to tell them apart. Because essentially, the great king, the king of Persia, the king of kings, his role is divorced from the kind of humanity. He rules not as a kind of individual person who is inherited the throne
并且不可避免地将他们自己的统治者视为光明和真理，而将所有反对他们的人视为黑暗与虚伪。这意味着，从本质上讲，根本没有必要去描述他们在做什么，因为一切都是完美的。他们创造了人类文明可能成为的一切事物的绝对精髓。既然如此，还有什么好写的呢？好吧，这可不是当历史学家得好地方。不，这简直是个糟糕透顶的地方。以至于当你看到对波斯国王（如大流士、薛西斯或其他人）那些不可思议的描绘时，你往往分不清他们谁是谁。因为从本质上讲，伟大的国王，波斯之王，万王之王，他的角色与某种“人性”是脱节的。他统治的身份不是作为一个继承了王位的普通个人，
but as the essence of kingship that's why he is the king of kings that is his role and so therefore you don't get the kind of scandalous gossip that you get from greek historians or later roman historians which is why you know someone like darius or xerxes is a kind of much chillier, much more anonymous figure than, say, the Spartan or the Athenian leaders. Yeah. Themistocles. Okay, so let's talk about how it all, why does it happen? Greece is disunited, Greece is city-states, Persia is the great empire. Why on earth, if you're so rich and powerful, why do they even bother attacking the greeks what's the story well i think it's it's partly because empires have to expand particularly if you feel that you have a kind of moral mission yeah to pacify the world because inevitably on along your borders there
而是作为王权的本质。这就是为什么他是万王之王，这就是他的角色。因此，你不会从他身上看到希腊历史学家或后来的罗马历史学家那种声名狼藉的八卦绯闻。这就是为什么像大流士或薛西斯这样的人，比斯巴达或雅典的领袖们要冷冰冰得多、也匿名得多。是的。地米斯托克利。好吧，让我们谈谈这一切是如何发生的，为什么会发生？希腊四分五裂，全是一个个城邦，而波斯则是伟大的帝国。既然你们如此富有和强大，为什么还要费劲去攻击希腊人呢？这背后到底有什么故事？嗯，我想部分原因在于帝国必须扩张，特别是当你觉得你有一种类似道德使命的愿望来安抚世界时。因为在你的边境上，
are going to be kind of fracture points and the greeks are a very fractious people they are very given to rebellion and in the 490s bc the greeks who've been conquered were conquered by cyrus's armies um in the mid-sixth century so these are all the cities on the coast they're called ionia yeah so they're called the ionians and the ionians rebel and the ionians look across the the sea to the great cities of Greece proper for support. And first of all, they come to Sparta and the Spartans are a very kind of insular crabbed people. And although Cleomenes, who we talked about in the Sparta episode, although he is a kind of expansive guy he you know he he's not he doesn't want to cross the sea he he doesn't want to go on kind of great alexander style adventures and so he says no and so then the ionian ambassador goes to athens and athens
不可避免地会出现断层线，而希腊人是一个非常分裂的民族，极易发生叛乱。在公元前490年代，那些被塞浦路斯的军队——哦不，被居鲁士的军队在公元前六世纪中叶征服的希腊人——这些沿海的城市被称为伊奥尼亚，是的，他们被称为伊奥尼亚人。伊奥尼亚人爆发了叛乱，他们隔海向希腊本土的伟大城市寻求支持。首先，他们找到了斯巴达。斯巴达人是一个非常孤立、思想保守的民族。尽管克里昂米尼——我们在斯巴达那一集里谈到过他——尽管他是一个有扩张欲的人，
is a revolutionary state it's it's chucked out this guy hippias who um it is a tyrant and a tyrant doesn't quite have the meaning that has in contemporary english it's more like a kind of uh a latin american dictator it's that kind of uh peron he's a kind of peronist figure he's been expelled and the athenians have embarked on this kind of radical political project that we know is democracy uh and and democracy today it doesn't quite have the connotations that it would have had for the athenians because for the athenians it's it's the demos the people that has the the kratos the power the demos is everyone who who's living who has lived and who will live who have sprung from the soil of Attica. So it's deeply, deeply rooted in a sense of place. The Athenians came to be autochthonous,
他不想跨越大海，不想去进行亚历山大大帝那种风格的伟大冒险，所以他拒绝了。于是伊奥尼亚大使去了雅典。雅典是一个革命国家，它刚刚驱逐了一个叫希庇ias的家伙，他是一个暴君——这里的“暴君”并不完全具备现代英语中的那个贬义词含义，它更像是某种……拉丁美洲式的独裁者，类似于庇隆那样的人物。他被驱逐了，雅典人踏上了一种我们所知的被称为民主制的激进政治实验。而今天的民主制，它所带有的内涵与雅典人当时的理解并不完全一样。因为对于雅典人来说，是“德莫斯”（demos，人民）拥有“克拉托斯”（kratos，权力）。“德莫斯”指的是所有曾经活着、现在活着以及将要活着、从阿提卡大地中涌现出来的人。因此，它深深地、深深地植根于一种地方感。雅典人自认为是“本土生长的”，
sprung from the soil. They're not immigrants. And the democracy, the power that is given to this people is kind of expressive of this deeply weird, deeply supernatural sense of community that the Athenian people have with themselves, with the soil and with the gods, and particularly with Athena, who is their patron. And it's a state that, because there is this kind of sense of commonality that hadn't been there under the rule of the Peronist hippias, it's a kind of ferment of experimentation. They're kind of flexing their muscles. They're trying to test what they can do with this new sense of power, this new political experiment
从土地中破土而出。他们不是移民。赋予这群人民的民主与权力，表达了雅典人民对自己、对土地、对神灵（尤其是他们的保护神雅典娜）所拥有的一种极其诡异、极其超自然的社群感。由于在庇隆式的希庇ias统治时期所没有的那种共同体意识的存在，这个国家变成了一个充满试验的发酵炉。他们正在展示肌肉，试图测试他们能用这种新获得的权力、用他们正在进行的这项新的政治实验做些什么。
that they're running. And so they sign up to joining the Ionians. Just a quick question about the Ionians. When they rebel against the Persian Empire, I mean, they're not rebelling. Are they rebelling because they don't like paying tribute, basically? Is it a tax rebellion? I mean, presumably they're not rebelling because they have a sense of Greekness and the Persian overlord offends that, because the Persian king rules tons of different kinds of people. He rules Bactrians and Egyptians and Carmanians and all sorts. So there's nothing wrong with being ruled by the Persian king, right?
于是他们签署了加入伊奥尼亚人阵营的协议。关于伊奥尼亚人，我有一个简单的问题。当他们反抗波斯帝国时，我的意思是，他们不是在反抗吗？他们反抗基本上是因为他们不喜欢交贡赋吗？这是一场税收叛乱吗？我的意思是，大概他们反抗不是因为他们有一种希腊认同感、而波斯宗主国的存在冒犯了这一点吧？因为波斯国王统治着大量不同种类的人。他统治着巴克特里亚人、埃及人、卡尔曼人等等。所以被波斯国王统治并没有什么不对的，对吧？
Yeah, there is a kind of resentment about it. There's a resentment about the tribute. I agree. I mean, you know, they'd been ruled before the Persians, they'd been ruled by the Lydians. So they're used to paying tribute. But I think there's a kind of constant snarl of, again, in Ionia, as in Athens,
是的，对此确实存在一种怨恨。对贡赋存在怨恨，我同意。我的意思是，在波斯人之前，他们曾被吕底亚人统治过。所以他们习惯了缴纳贡赋。但我认为有一种持续存在的摩擦，在伊奥尼亚就像在雅典一样，
there's a kind of tension between people who are tyrants, people who resent being ruled as tyrants, individual ambitions, kind of a hint of class warfare. These are very, very unstable places politically. And so the kind of the yearning for freedom, the yearning to cast off Persian tributary power is kind of gets mixed in with the personal ambitions of the leadership. It's that that generates the impulse to to rebel and it's what makes the athenians kind of such natural allies yeah and and the guy who persuades the athenians to join in says that you know it's it was easier to persuade 10 000 men in athens than it was to persuade one man cleomenes in
在暴君与痛恨作为暴君被统治的人之间存在着一种紧张关系，夹杂着个人的野心，甚至带有一点阶级斗争的意味。这些地方在政治上非常不稳定。因此，对自由的渴望、对摆脱波斯朝贡权力的渴望，与领导层的个人野心交织在了一起。正是这种动力激发了反叛的冲动，这也使得雅典人成为了如此天然的同盟。那个说服雅典人加入的人曾说过，说服雅典的1万人，比说服斯巴达的那个独夫克里昂米尼要容易得多。
sparta and and there is this sense that you know know, that this is an uprising, not just against the Persians, but against the kind of the ruling classes that were the kind of the Petanists in these Ionian cities. So the Athenians, you know, they send some ships and Herodotus says that this was the beginning of the great process of chaos that was to convulse the world, these ships going. And the kind of echoes of the Trojan War there, which also herodotus is kind of drawing out so the athenians go then they join in uh an expedition to go and attack the persian governor in sardis which was the former capital of the lydian empire um croesus came from sardis yeah croesus who invented money came from there the founding father of this podcast yes exactly so so the athenians join in the attack they they capture um sardis but they don't capture the acropolis the kind of the high point the high city um which holds out and disastrously they accidentally set fire to
而且确实有这样一种感觉：这不仅是对波斯的起义，也是对这些伊奥尼亚城市中作为“庇隆主义者”的统治阶级的起义。于是雅典人派遣了一些船只，希罗多德说，这标志着那场将震撼世界的混乱大过程的开始，正是这些船只的出行。其中隐约带有特洛伊战争的影子，这也是希罗多德试图勾勒出来的。于是雅典人出发了，他们加入了一场旨在攻击萨尔迪斯的波斯总督的远征。萨尔迪斯是吕底亚帝国的旧都，克罗伊索斯就来自萨尔迪斯——是的，那个发明了货币的克罗伊索斯，本播客的始祖鸟，没错，正是如此。所以雅典人加入了这次进攻，他们占领了萨尔迪斯，但没有攻下卫城——那座高地上的高耸城市，那里仍在坚守。灾难性的是，他们在无意中放火烧了
the city and this burns down various temples and the athenians are so kind of appalled at having done this that they all retreat the the pers Persian you know they get cavalry they attack the Ionians are defeated the Athenians skedaddle back to um back to Athens there's a kind of enormous sense of anxiety not just that they have kind of tweaked the the tale of the of the Persian um great beast but also that they've offended the gods and so basically they kind of there's a kind of agreement they're just going to forget about it you know let's just pretend this didn't happen and meanwhile on the other side the Persians are kind of moving in for the kill they raise a great fleet the the Ionians are cornered outside Miletus which is the center
这座城市，大火烧毁了几座神庙。雅典人对自己的所作所为感到震惊，于是全军撤退。波斯人调集了骑兵，攻击了伊奥尼亚人，伊奥尼亚人战败了，雅典人则夹着尾巴逃回了雅典。雅典人心中涌起巨大的焦虑，不仅因为他们拔了波斯这头大野兽的胡须，还因为他们冒犯了神明。因此基本上他们达成了一种默契，决定把这件事忘掉，“让我们假装这一切从未发生过吧”。与此同时，在另一边，波斯人正步步紧逼准备痛下杀手。他们集结了一支庞大的舰队，伊奥尼亚人被一个叫拉德的岛屿附近、米利都（这场叛乱的中心）郊外的海军基地逼入绝境，整个舰队瞬间土崩瓦解。因为波斯人在作战时最擅长的是施加压倒性的力量——他们确实拥有这种力量，可以从整个帝国各处征召舰队；
of this rebellion by an island called Lade and the entire fleet just disintegrates because what the persians are brilliant at when they fight they're brilliant at bringing overwhelming force which they have they can muster fleets from across the empire yeah um they're very very good at kind of data resourcing so they know exactly you know who is in with who and they're very very good at espionage they're very good at kind of getting secret agents and so they use gold basically to foster dissension among the the ionians and the whole battle fleet just disintegrates and then the persian fleet moves in and mops it up they then sack miletus and they take away the inhabitants to Persia.
他们非常非常擅长数据资源调配，能确切地知道谁和谁是一伙的；他们极其擅长间谍活动，擅长收买秘密特工。因此，他们基本上是通过金钱来挑拨伊奥尼亚人之间的不和，结果整个战作战舰队就这样土崩瓦解了。随后，波斯舰队长驱直入，进行清剿。他们接着洗劫了米利都，并将居民押送到波斯。
The boys are castrated. The girls are sold as slaves. It's hideous. And when a play is staged in Athens about the fall of Miletus, the playwright is fined. The play is banned. And the Athenians,
男孩们被阉割，女孩们被当成奴隶卖掉。这太可怕了。当雅典上演一出关于米利都沦陷的戏剧时，剧作家被罚款，戏剧遭到禁演。雅典人
they just don't want to know about it. The whole thing is appalling. Because they feel guilty or because they... I think they feel a sense of shame that they let the Milesians and the Ionians down. They feel guilt that they burnt down the temples in Sardis and therefore the gods are against them. And they're frankly crapping themselves. I thought of what the Persians might do quite correctly. Yeah, so the Persians,
简直不愿提及此事。整件事骇人听闻。因为他们感到内疚，还是因为他们……我想他们感到一种羞耻感，觉得他们辜负了米利都人和伊奥尼亚人。他们为烧毁了萨尔迪斯的庙宇而感到负罪，觉得神明在与他们作对。坦白说，他们吓得屁滚尿流。
now at this stage, the Persians could let sleeping dogs lie as they were. They could just say, right, well, that's it. But they're presumably determined to teach the Athenians a lesson, aren't they? Exactly. And it's exactly like the Americans going to Afghanistan after the burning down of 9-11.
在现阶段，本可以像以前那样息事宁人。他们完全可以大笔一挥：“好吧，就这样吧。”但他们大概是铁了心要给雅典人一个教训，不是吗？正是如此。这完全就像9·11事件后美国人前往阿富汗一样。
These guys are harbouring terrorists. They're a terrorist state. They're a terrorist state. You know, Athens is kind of the equivalent of Al-Qaeda yeah yeah you know we've got to root them out yes uh we've you know we for the good of the world you know it's not just kind of persian ammo proper it's it's but we have a duty so we need to bring truth we need to bring order and and athens is seen as a nest of davers of demons you know they need to purge athens with fire that's very kind of post 9-11 isn't it yeah and they so the george bush of this scenario is darius the great is that right
这些家伙在窝藏恐怖分子。他们是一个恐怖主义国家。雅典基本上就相当于基地组织。我们要把他们连根拔起。为了世界的利益——这不仅是波斯人正当的愤怒，更是我们的责任。我们需要带去真理，我们需要带去秩序。雅典被视为恶魔与巢穴的温床，他们需要用烈火来涤荡雅典。这非常具有“后9·11时代”的色彩，不是吗？是的。所以这个剧本里的乔治·布什就是大流士大帝，对吧？
he's that is right yes and so does he go himself he goes himself he's far too important to bother with with you know it's basically they see it as border policing yeah it's a sort of punitive raid basically more than yeah yes yes i mean it has to be done, obviously, for kind of reasons of realpolitik. You can't allow people to just come along and burn a city and attack you and then not be punished for it. But there is also this kind of cosmic dimension.
正是如此。所以他自己去了吗？他亲自前往。他身份尊贵，才不会亲自去处理这种……这基本上被视为边境治安。这更像是一次惩罚性突袭，而不是……是的，是的。我的意思是，出于现实政治的考虑，这显然是必须的。你不能允许人们随便跑来烧毁一座城市、攻击你却不用受到惩罚。但这里也有这种宇宙维度的考量。
So an amphibious expedition is sent across the Aegean. First of all, it attacks the city of Eretria, which is in Euboea, Euboea today kind of long thin narrow island yes that is north of attica that gets captured then they land on the plane of marathon the athenians rather than hunker down inside their city send all their soldiers hoplites named after the hoplon the the heavy shield that the heavy the armored infantry carry they actually march out to try and meet with the with the persians they also send a messenger running all the way to ath to sparta to try and get the spartans to come and join them the spartans are celebrating a festival so can't but say that they will come there you know when it's over in a week's time thanks for that yeah cheers guys
于是，一支两栖远征军被派遣跨越爱琴海。首先，它攻击了埃维亚岛上的埃雷特里亚城。今天的埃维亚岛是一个狭长的岛屿，位于阿提卡以北。该城被攻陷后，他们登陆了马拉松平原。雅典人没有龟缩在城市里，而是派出了他们所有的士兵——被称为“重步兵”（hoplites）的军队，这个词得名于重步兵们携带的大型圆形盾牌“霍普隆”（hoplon）。他们实际上开拔出城，试图与波斯人正面交锋。他们还派出一名信使一路狂奔到斯巴达，试图请求斯巴达人前来增援。当时斯巴达人正在庆祝一个节日，因此无法成行，但承诺说等一周后的节日结束就会赶来。“谢谢你们啊，哥们儿，真够意思。”
the only people who come to the athenian rescue is from the tiny town of platea which the athenians had backed in their war against thebes which is the kind of the big heavyweight city of boeotia the region just next to attica um so the platoons do come and join but there are hardly any so there's a any. So there's a kind of standoff above the plane of marathon. And then the Athenians see that the Persians are starting to load troops onto their ships. And a message comes that the cavalry is being loaded on. And this means both that maybe these ships are heading around the headland to go to Athens to attack it directly while there's no one to defend it but it also means that you know that the infantry can march down into the plain and they won't be attacked by cavalry and so this is what the Athenians do
唯一前来支援雅典人的，是来自小镇普拉提亚的军队。雅典人曾在普拉提亚人与底比斯（作为波斯人在博奥西亚地区的最大重镇，也是紧邻阿提卡的地区）的战争中支持过他们。所以普拉提亚人确实赶来增援了，但人数寥寥无几。因此在马拉松平原上方，形成了一种对峙的僵局。随后，雅典人看到波斯人开始将部队装载上船。有消息传来，骑兵正在被装船。这意味着两件事：一方面，也许这些趁着无人防守时，正绕过岬角直接攻击雅典；另一方面，这也意味着步兵可以下山开进平原，而不必担心遭到骑兵的袭击。于是雅典人果断行动了。
no Greek army had ever defeated the Persians in pitch battle so it took you know they're massively outnumbered it takes incredible courage courage. They charge down the hill. Last kind of stretch, they start to run. They smash into the Persian line. The Athenians have weakened the centre of their line. So the centre of the Persian line goes forward, but the Athenians are then able to kind of turn and pincer it. Yes, to sort of envelop it, I guess.
此前没有任何一支希腊军队能够在阵地战中战胜波斯人。因此，尽管他们在数量上处于绝对劣势，这仍需要难以置信的勇气。他们冲下山坡。在最后一段冲刺时，他们开始奔跑，猛烈地撞入波斯阵线。雅典人削弱了自己阵型中央的兵力，因此波斯阵线的中央向前突进，但雅典人随后得以迂回并实施两翼包抄。是的，可以说是将其包围。
Envelop it. And they kind of play on on persian overconfidence because the persians push forwards in this kind of way because they assume that they're going to defeat them because they've always defeated the greeks but instead it's the athenians who win the athenians then rush back to athens to make sure that that the persians can't kind of snip around and capture athens while they're away the persian fleet moves into the harbor of of Phaleron. They see the Athenian hoplites drawn up on the harbour front. They kind of pause and then the sun sets and the Persian fleet withdraws. And the Athenians have seen the Persians off.
将其合围。他们利用了波斯人的过度自信，因为波斯人以这种方式向前推进，是假设自己必定会击败希腊人，毕竟他们过去总是击败希腊人。然而相反，最终获胜的是雅典人。随后，雅典人火速赶回雅典，以确保波斯人不会趁他们不在时迂回偷袭并攻占雅典。波斯舰队驶入法勒龙港。当他们看到港口前严阵以待的雅典重步兵时，舰队停顿了一下，随后太阳落山，波斯舰队撤退了。雅典人成功击退了波斯人。
And, of course, this is the greatest thing that the Athenians have ever done. They've lost 190. The persians have lost thousands and thousands they build a great kind of funeral memorial for it the spartans arrive late they go and inspect the persian dead you know pay the athenians great compliments there's there's basically the kind of the athenians relax they think we've seen the persians off we're brilliant you know we're heroic it's the hoplite class. It's the kind of the people who can afford armour who did it. Brilliant. However.
当然，这是雅典人有生以来做过的最伟大的事情。他们阵亡了190人，而波斯人则损失了成千上万。他们为此建立了一座宏伟的阵亡将士纪念碑。斯巴达人姗姗来迟，他们前去检视波斯人的尸体，向雅典人表达了崇高的敬意。基本上，雅典人松了一口气，觉得自己把波斯人打退了，我们太棒了，我们太英勇了，这就是重步兵阶层的功劳。太辉煌了。然而。
Yes. Yeah. Well, this is the perfect point to take a break. And when we return, I guess we'll be getting into the Battle of Thermopylae. Very exciting. See you after the break. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman.
是的。好吧，这正是中场休息的绝佳时机。等我们回来时，我想我们要进入温泉关战役了。非常令人兴奋。休息后见。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。
And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. dot com Welcome back to The Rest Is History. We're talking about the Persian Wars and specifically the Battle of Thermopylae. So the Athenians have just wiped the floor with the Persians at Marathon, Tom, and are very overconfident. But they've got a shock coming, haven't they? Because the Persians are going to come back for more. It comes as a shock to most people in Athens. Most people in Athens assume that everything is fine,
我们共同主持《娱乐其余部分》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、一丝八卦爆料的地方，在我们的问答环节中，我们将拉开娱乐业的帷幕，向你展示这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚启动了会员俱乐部。如果你想无广告收听、获得加更节目以及提前购买现场演出门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史其余部分》。我们正在讨论希波战争，特别是温泉关战役。所以雅典人刚刚在马拉松战役中把波斯人打得落花流水，汤姆，并且信心极度膨胀。但他们即将迎来一个巨大的打击，不是吗？因为波斯人卷土重来了。这给雅典的大多数人带来了震惊。雅典绝大多数人都认为一切都好，
that the Persians have gone. But there are those who, kind of Churchill-like, are looking to the future and recognising the full scale of the kind of storm that is gathering. And of these, the ablest is a man called Themistocles. Yeah. Who is a kind of a child of the democratic revolution. So he's grown up as a political figure, really only knowing the democracy.
波斯人已经走了。但也有一些人，像丘吉尔那样，放眼未来，认到了正在聚集的风暴的全部规模。在这些人中，最能干的是一个名叫地米斯托克利的人。是的，他是民主革命的产物。所以作为一个政治人物，他成长时所了解的基本上只有民主制。
So he's that first generation. And in a sense, he's the kind of the prototype of the democratic politician. So he's become a kind of a legal figure so he's the first person to become a lawyer and recognize that this is a good way to kind of prepare yourself for politics he also understands that the implications of the democracy the fact that everybody now has a vote and a say is that if you start appealing to to people who don't necessarily have large amounts of property who don't necessarily have enough money to to own armor they're a resource you can get their votes and so he starts to appeal to yeah he's a populist so he's stuck well or you could say he's um
所以他是第一代。从某种意义上说，他是民主政客的原型。所以他变成了一种法律界人士，他是第一个成为律师并认识到这是为从政做准备的好方法的人，他也明白民主的含义，即现在每个人都有投票权和发言权，这意味着如果你开始吸引那些不一定拥有大量财产、没有足够资金拥有盔甲的人，他们就是一种资源，你可以得到他们的选票，所以他开始吸引——是的，他是个民粹主义者，所以他被困住了，或者你可以说他是，呃
well he's appealing to the people whether that makes you a populist or a socialist or i mean he's not a socialist but he's he's he's someone who who's who is a man of the people yeah like you yes just like me that's exactly the comparison i was thinking of and he therefore argues that the focus of athens should be on boosting its naval power. And the harbour of Phaleron that the Persian fleet had approached after Marathon is inadequate. It's not large enough. It's too exposed. There is another place, a place called, a bay called Piraeus, which is further from Athens itself, about two miles further, but is much better protected. And if developed, could make a kind of an amazing, amazing harbour.
嗯，他在吸引人民，不管这让你成为一个民粹主义者还是社会主义者，我的意思是，他不是一个社会主义者，但他是一个人民的人，是的，就像你一样，是的，就像我一样，这正是我所想的比较，因此他认为雅典的重心应该是增强其海军力量。波斯舰队在马拉松战役后接近的法勒隆港是不够的。它不够大。它太暴露了。还有一个地方，一个叫比雷埃夫斯的海湾，距离雅典本身更远，大约远了两英里，但受到的保护要好得多。如果开发得当，可以成为一个非常惊人的港口。
And so Themistocles pushes this through. And it's a way of kind of, you know, it's calculated to appeal to those who are poorer, those who will get money to develop it, those who will then be able to make money from kind of, you know, profiting from the increased trade and everything. So this is very popular but Themistocles also has his eyes on on making Athens a great naval power as well as a great trading power and just in the nick of time so Battle of Marathons 490 this happens in 483 a massive seam of silver is discovered at a place of called Lauryon which is on the kind of attic coast east of Athens. You know, it's a prodigious amount of cash that is opened up.
于是地米斯托克利推动了这件事。这是一种旨在吸引穷人、那些将获得资金开发它的人、那些随后能够从贸易增长和一切中获利的人的方法。所以这非常受欢迎，但地米斯托克利也着眼于使雅典成为一个伟大的海军强国以及一个伟大的贸易强国，而且恰到好处——马拉松战役在公元前490年，这件事发生在公元前483年，在劳里昂发现了一个巨大的银脉，劳里昂位于雅典以东的阿提卡海岸。你知道，这是一笔惊人的财富。
And so there's a debate as to what should be done with this money. Traditionally, when kind of windfalls happen like this happen, it's shared out among the people and that obviously has appeal. And so there's a guy called Aristides who is nicknamed the just because he's a figure of such kind of moral probity. He argues that the silver should be shared out among everybody in Athens.
因此，关于如何处理这笔钱展开了辩论。传统上，当这种意外之财发生时，它会在人民中间平分，这显然很有吸引力。因此，有一个叫阿里斯蒂德斯的人，被称为“公正者”，因为他是一个具有高度道德正直的人。他认为这笔银子应该在雅典的每个人中间平分。
Themistocles argues, no, we should invest this money in a fleet. We should make ourselves the greatest power in Greece. And he doesn't argue this because the persians are coming because he knows that lots of people aren't worried about that and he doesn't want to seem like a kind of you know kind of whipping up phantoms but instead there is athens has a great rival the island of aegina which lies just off attica and so he says we could build a huge fleet and then we could beat the crap out of aegina and this and this is very popular you
地米斯托克利则认为，不，我们应该把这笔钱投资于舰队。我们应该让自己成为希腊最强大的力量。他提出这一点并不是因为波斯人要来了，因为他知道很多人并不担心这一点，他也不想显得像是在煽动幻觉，相反，雅典有一个强大的对手，那就是埃伊纳岛，它就位于阿提卡附近，所以他说我们可以建造一支庞大的舰队，然后我们可以狠狠地揍埃伊纳一顿，这非常受欢迎，你知道
know so he's not like this so he's not churchill then he is churchill because he is looking at he's looking at persia but he's disguising the fact that that's what he's doing he's basically saying you know let's build this fleet so we can we can attack aegina but all along he's he's he knows that the real challenge is is persia so this he and aristides have to basically argue the torso for this and the argument is is so bitter and so impossible to resolve that um this kind of novel political technique called ostracism has to be drawn on and ostraca are kind of shards of pottery and if there are two major kind of political figures in the democracy who are basically disrupting it and they can't be reconciled the athenians will have a vote to
所以他不像这个——所以他不是丘吉尔？不，他就是丘吉尔，因为他在关注波斯，但他掩盖了他在做这件事的事实，他基本上是在说，你知道，让我们建造这支舰队，这样我们就可以攻击埃伊纳，但自始至终，他都知道真正的挑战是波斯。因此，他和阿里斯蒂德斯不得不为此争论不休，争论是如此激烈，如此难以解决，以至于不得不借助一种叫做“陶片放逐法”的新颖政治技术，陶片是陶器的碎片，如果民主政体中有两个主要的政治人物基本上在破坏它，且无法和解，雅典人就会进行投票
decide which one should be sent into exile for 10 years and they write the name down on these ostraca on these fragments of pottery and themistocles and Aristides are put up for ostracism and effectively it's the first referendum in history because essentially they are voting on whether to spend the money on the fleet or not yeah so so much rides on this referendum yeah and it's Aristides who ends up being exiled Themistocles his policy is passed the investment goes into the fleet and it's in 482 481 that everyone starts to realize that actually the persians are coming well this is what i was going to ask what are the persians doing while all this is going on so darius is still king am i right darius dies shortly after the battle of marathon okay so he's gone so he is
决定谁应该被流放10年，他们把名字写在这些陶片上，把地米斯托克利和阿里斯蒂德斯置于陶片放逐法的表决之下，这实际上是历史上第一次公投，因为本质上他们是在投票决定是否把钱花在舰队上，是的，所以这次公投关系重大，是的，最后被流放的是阿里斯蒂德斯，地米斯托克利的政策通过了，资金投入到了舰队中，正是在公元前482年到481年，大家才开始意识到波斯人真的要来了。这就是我要问的，在这一切发生的时候波斯人在做什么？所以大流士仍然是国王，我没记错吧？大流士在马拉松战役后不久就去世了。好吧，所以他不在了。所以他
he and he is succeeded by one of his many sons a man called xerxes great name great great name and a great guy i mean he's he's seen as the kind of the archetype of a tyrant uh you know a hubristic idiot who who fails because the the greeks write the history but he's a man of formidable capabilities um because he's a persian prince he's the he's the uh the grandson of cyrus um darius comes from a different family but darius has married um cyrus's daughter atossa brilliant atossa yeah whether she was atossa who knows but tom come on calm down that's a below me isn't it that's a terrible joke she so she's a kind of formidable queen mother figure but Xerxes himself is is imposed physically imposing he's been trained he's tough he's been trained in in all the attributes of war he's also a great gardener Persians are very very they love
他由他的众多儿子之一继承，一个叫薛西斯的人，好名字，好名字，也是个好家伙，我的意思是，他被视为暴君的原型，呃，你知道，一个傲慢的笨蛋，因为希腊人写了历史而失败，但他是一个能力非凡的人，因为他是一个波斯王子，他是居鲁士的孙子，大流士来自一个不同的家庭，但大流士娶了居鲁士的女儿阿托莎，聪明的阿托莎，是的，管她是不是阿托莎呢，好了，冷静点，这有点失水准了吧？这是一个糟糕的玩笑，所以她是一个强大的王太后式的人物，但薛西斯本人外表威严，受过训练，坚韧不拔，在战争的各项素质中都受过训练，他也是一个伟大的园丁，波斯人非常非常喜欢
their gardens they love their gardens and um there's a kind of war party in Persia that is saying um you know we should definitely invade greece and one of the ways that they that they get xerxes to agree to this is to say that that europe has kind of amazing trees you could get some beautiful trees for your garden it's kind of saying it's like yeah it's a gardening garden center well like napoleon napoleon was very into his gardening there's a whole book about napoleon and gardening yes the risk go one isn't it yes yes uh well xerxes is the same so xerxes absolutely loves his trees loves his plants um saplings and stuff and so he decides yes we you know i have a duty to the persian people to the empire but above all to uh to you know the cosmic balance of good and evil to to invade greece and to punish uh not just the
他们的花园，他们喜欢他们的花园，呃，波斯有一个主战派，在说，呃，你知道，我们绝对应该入侵希腊，他们让薛西斯同意这一点的方法之一就是说欧洲有奇妙的树木，你可以为你的花园弄到一些漂亮的树木，这有点像是，是的，就像一个园艺中心。嗯，就像拿破仑，拿破仑非常热衷于园艺，有一整本关于拿破仑和园艺的书，是的，里斯科是一个，对吧？是的，是的，嗯，薛西斯也是一样，所以薛西斯绝对喜欢他的树，喜欢他的植物、树苗之类的人，所以他决定，是的，我们，你知道，我对波斯人民、对帝国负有责任，但最重要的是对善恶的宇宙平衡负责，入侵希腊，惩罚不仅是
athenians but also the Spartans because before Marathon Darius had sent ambassadors around Greece asking for earth and water which is the symbol of submission everybody given it apart from the Athenians who put them on trial the ambassadors on trial and executed them and the Spartans who famously chucked them down a well right so you can sort of see that from Xerxes perspective he's punishing two terrorist states yes athens and sparta who are you know they they represent disorder anarchy violence they treat ambassadors with scorn they don't hand over the earth and water they're just bad people they are bad people and that's absolutely yes they are bad they they are evil
雅典人，还有斯巴达人，因为在马拉松战役之前，大流士曾派特使环游希腊索要土地和水，这是臣服的象征，除了雅典人把他们送上审判、将特使交付审判并处决他们，以及斯巴达人把他们扔进井里之外，所有人都交了，对吧？所以你可以看出，从薛西斯的角度来看，他在惩罚两个恐怖主义国家，是的，雅典和斯巴达，他们代表着混乱、无政府状态、暴力，他们对特使不屑一顾，不交出土地和水，他们就是坏人，他们是坏人，绝对是的，他们是坏的，他们是邪恶的
that's exactly yeah the you know it's an axis of evil Athens and Sparta and the Spartans feel the Spartans are kind of paranoid about actually about the the crime that they've committed in murdering the the assassins and they actually send two Spartans to Xerxes to try and kind of make up for it and you know Xerxes doesn't kill them because he knows it's much better to leave the Spartans stewing in a sense of guilt um so essentially Xerxes feels that he's on a moral mission yeah but he also feels that of course when he's invading Greece he's doing it as the king of kings as the as the king of the universe and therefore he can't as Persians under cyrus had done do this kind of the persians under cyrus have been very mobile essentially kind of based on horses um just persians just the medes
完全是这样，你知道，雅典和斯巴达是邪恶轴心，斯巴达人感到——斯巴达人实际上对他们谋杀刺客所犯下的罪行感到偏执，他们实际上派了两个斯巴达人去见薛西斯，试图弥补过失，你知道薛西斯没有杀他们，因为他知道让斯巴达人在负罪感中煎熬要好得多，所以本质上薛西斯觉得他在进行一项道德使命，是的，但他也觉得，当然，当他入侵希腊时，他是作为万王之王、作为宇宙之王这样做的，因此他不能像居鲁士统治下的波斯人那样做，居鲁士统治下的波斯人非常机动，基本上是以马匹为基础的，只有波斯人，只有米底人
very very swift very effective um xerxes can't invade greece in that way because he's he's the king of of the empire so therefore he has to take a force that is appropriate to his status as the king of the world. And so therefore, as well as all his kind of hardened troops, the Persians, the Medes and so on, he also has to bring people from every corner of the empire.
非常非常迅捷，非常有效，薛西斯不能以那种方式入侵希腊，因为他是帝国的国王，因此他必须带领一支与其世界之王地位相称的军队。因此，除了他所有的百战精兵——波斯人、米底人等等之外，他还必须把帝国各个角落的人都带来。
Even if they're no good at fighting? Even if they're no good at fighting at all. So, you know, people who are armed with kind of stone tip spears and stone axes and things like that, they all have to come along. And this in turn makes it makes it very problematic to get them there because it he can't you know if he's
即使他们不擅长战斗？即使他们一点也不擅长战斗。所以，你知道，那些装备着石尖长矛和石斧之类东西的人，都必须跟着来。而这反过来又使得把他们带到那里变得非常成问题，因为他不能，你知道，如果他
bringing this size force and there are arguments about how large it is so that thing you passage from her it says three million people which is obviously completely exaggerated well that's the poem that he's quoting herodotus actually says it's about 1,070,000 people. I mean, that's obviously also a ludicrous figure. I guess it's about 250,000, 300,000. I mean, it's enormous. I mean, that's a larger force than anything up to D-Day. I mean, it's on an enormous scale, but they can't take them across in ships because there aren't enough so that means that they've got to march across the hellespont on pontoon bridges or something how do they get across the hellespont and they've got to take a fleet okay so they have to kind of go in sync well how do they cross the hellespont i mean that's that's exactly that's exactly the problem
带来这么大规模的军队——关于军队有多大有很多争论，希罗多德的那段话说是300万人，这显然被完全夸大了。嗯，那是他在引用的诗句，希罗多德实际上说大约有1,070,000人。我的意思是，这显然也是一个荒谬的数字。我想大概是25만到30万人吧。我的意思是，这太庞大了。我的意思是，这是D日之前规模最大的军队。我的意思是，这规模极其庞大，但他们不能用船运送过去，因为数量不够，这意味着他们必须通过浮桥之类的东西走过赫勒斯滂。他们是怎么过赫勒斯滂的？他们必须带一支舰队。好吧，所以他们必须同步前进。好吧，他们是怎么过赫勒斯滂的？我的意思是，这正是问题所在。
well they build two pontoon bridges. Right, okay. And the pontoon, there's a great storm in the winter and they get smashed up, so they have to be rebuilt. And the Greeks are absolutely shocked because the sea is punished symbolically by being branded and having fetters thrown into it. And this is seen as kind of massive, offensive to Poseidon, the god of the sea.
好吧，他们建了两座浮桥。好吧，知道了。浮桥在冬天遇到了大风暴，被撞毁了，所以必须重建。希腊人感到震惊，因为海水受到了象征性的惩罚，被烙印并扔进去了脚镣。这被视为对海神波塞冬的极大的冒犯。
Where the sea was gutted. Yeah, well, we'll find out whether the sea was gutted. Yeah, well, we'll find out whether the sea was gutted, because in due course, this becomes a kind of important part of the story, the vengeance of Poseidon for this. But also what they do is, there'd been a fleet earlier that had sunk around Mount Athos. And according to Rodas, the shipwreck sailors had all been eaten by sea monsters. I mean, I don't know, who were they what were they we don't know and so xerxes has commissioned people to laborers to build canals you know the three prongs of the athos peninsula the canals are kind of dug through so that the fleet can just go straight through it and not risk being shipwrecked so enormous preparations are made and obviously
海水被开肠破肚了。是的，好吧，我们会发现海水是否被开肠破肚了，是的，好吧，我们会发现海水是否被开肠破肚了，因为在适当的时候，这成为了故事的重要部分，波塞冬对此的复仇。但他们也做了什么呢，之前有一支舰队在阿托斯山附近沉没过。根据希罗多德的说法，遭遇海难的水手都被海怪吃掉了。我的意思是，我不知道，他们是谁？他们是什么？我们不知道，所以薛西斯委托工匠建造运河，你知道，阿托斯半岛的三叉，运河被开凿出来，这样舰队就可以直接穿过去，而不会冒着遭遇海难的危险。因此，进行了巨大的准备工作，显而易见
the greeks even even the kind of the the dumbest greek has to realize the monstrous scale of what is coming and so in due course when xerxes arrives in sardis he winters there um they send spies over to find out how large the you know the invasion force is these spies get captured they're about to be executed when Xerxes' guards come running and say, what are you doing? The spies then get taken around. They get given full lists of everybody who's coming, all the brigades, all the ships and everything. Then they're sent back to the Greeks, who were all absolutely terrified. And so in Greece, the prospect of this monstrous army coming is not met with a kind of oval, you know,
希腊人——即使是最愚蠢的希腊人——也不得不意识到即将到来的庞大骇人的规模，因此，当薛西斯抵达萨尔迪斯并在那里过冬时，他们派间谍去查明入侵军队有多大，这些间谍被捕了，正要被处决时，薛西斯的卫兵跑过来说，你们在干什么？然后间谍被带去参观。他们得到了所有来者的完整名单，所有的旅、所有的船只以及一切。然后他们被送回希腊人那里，希腊人全都吓坏了。因此在希腊，面对这支庞大军队的到来，并没有产生一种全面性的、你知道的
a unanimous decision to resist it. The Athenians have to, the Spartans have to, because they're clearly toast. But it's not obvious that the other Greeks do. And because the Athenians and the Spartans have enemies among the Greeks, the likelihood is that Argos, the great rival in the Peloponnese for the rule, Sparta's great rival, who the Spartans hate, the Argives hate them. The Argives claim descent from a guy called Perseus, famous for chopping off the head of the Gorgon. And the Argives say that the Persians are descended from Perseus as in a sense they're kind of yeah so they're kin so maybe they should side with the persians and so they refuse basically to join they say the only way that they'll join is if they can lead the army and the spartans refuse that and they got argives know that they're going to refuse
一致抵抗的决定。雅典人必须抵抗，斯巴达人必须抵抗，因为他们显然死定了。但其他希腊人是否这样做并不明显。由于雅典人和斯巴达人在希腊人中有敌人，阿尔戈斯——伯罗奔尼撒半岛统治权的伟大竞争对手，斯巴达的强大对手，斯巴达人痛恨阿尔戈斯人，阿尔戈斯人也痛恨他们——很可能会倾向于波斯。阿尔戈斯人声称他们是珀尔修斯的后代，珀尔修斯因砍下蛇发女怪的头而闻名，阿尔戈斯人说波斯人也是珀尔修斯的后代，从某种意义上说，他们是亲属，所以也许他们应该站在波斯一边，因此他们基本上拒绝加入，他们说他们加入的唯一条件是他们必须领导军队，而斯巴达人拒绝了，阿尔戈斯人知道斯巴达人会拒绝
that so basically they're neutral and then the thebans because the the Athenians and the Thebans have been had this bust up over Plataea this kind of tiny town in in Boeotia that properly should be subordinate to Thebes but has become an Athenian ally the Thebans are gagging to side with the Persians as well and see Athens destroyed so the idea that this is a Persian a Greco-Persian war a clash between two civilizations Greece and Persia is is completely wrong, right? It's not completely wrong because the Greeks and the Persians have very, very different perspectives on things. But there are Greeks fighting on the Persian side, though, aren't there? Absolutely. And there are Greeks who will always regard a kind of outside force as a lesser threat than their immediate enemies.
所以基本上他们保持中立，然后底比斯人——因为雅典人和底比斯人在普拉提亚这件事上闹翻了，普拉提斯是维奥蒂亚的一个小镇，本来应该服从底比斯，但已经成为了雅典的盟友，底比斯人也极力想站在波斯一边，看到雅典被摧毁——所以认为这是一场波斯-希腊战争、是希腊和波斯两种文明之间冲突的想法是完全错误的，对吧？也不是完全错误，因为希腊人和波斯人对事物的看法非常非常不同。但是也有希腊人在波斯一方作战，对吧？绝对有。而且总有一些希腊人将外部势力视为比他们直接的敌人更小的威胁。
And the Persians know this and the persians are absolute masters of dividing and ruling and that's why their agents are everywhere they have an incredibly sophisticated espionage network tom i'm very conscious this episode is all about thermopylae but we're coming to thermopylae we haven't got we haven't got thermopylae well listen i tell you what we should do for this episode we should get the persians to the gates of thermopylae okay then we'll do thermopylae so we should call the episode the gates of thermopylae the road to thermopylae the road to thermopylae the road to thermopylae so so that's what you're listening to in case there's any uncertainty we've been going on too long no no it's fine i mean it's
波斯人知道这一点，波斯人是分而治之的绝对大师，这就是为什么他们的特工无处不在，他们拥有极其复杂的间谍网络。汤姆，我很清楚这一集讲的全是温泉关，但我们马上就讲到温泉关了，我们还没讲到温泉关呢。好吧，听着，我告诉你我们这一集应该做什么，我们应该把波斯人带到温泉关的大门前，好吧，然后我们再讲温泉关，所以我们应该把这一集叫做《温泉关之门》，通往温泉关之路，通往温泉关之路，通往温泉关之路。所以，如果你有任何不确定的话，这就是你正在收听的内容。我们是不是聊得太久了？不，不，没关系，我的意思是，这
not quite rater morley on the top 10 churches level of um level of delay and jeopardy. I should talk faster. Yeah. So, okay, there are Greeks on the Persian side and there are also Greek mercenaries, aren't there? The Persians always relied on Greek mercenaries. And obviously there must be Greeks from the Ionian coast. Absolutely. So the Ionians, they have to supply contingents of ships. So the great king marches from Sardis.
还算不上雷特·莫利关于十大教堂的延迟和悬念的水平。我应该说快一点。是的。好吧，好吧，波斯人那边有希腊人，也有希腊雇佣兵，对吧？波斯人一直依赖希腊雇佣兵。而且肯定有来自伊奥尼亚海岸的希腊人。绝对的。所以伊奥尼亚人必须提供舰队分遣队。于是大王从萨尔迪斯出发。
He marches up to Troy where he offers sacrifice offers sacrifice to athena yeah to show that you know there's no hard feelings about the fact he's going to destroy her city try and get her on board right then he he sits on uh this throne he all his fleet is out before him his armies oh yes i remember this scene in kind of famous scene great set piece herodotus describes and he he gazes out and then suddenly he bursts into tears, and his uncle asks him, why are you weeping? And Xerxes says, I'm looking out at this, all these men who are under my command,
他行军到特洛伊，在那里献祭，向雅典娜献祭，以表明，你知道，他要摧毁她的城市没有什么恶意，试着让她加入进来，对吧？然后他坐在宝座上，他所有的舰队都在他面前，他的军队——哦，是的，我记得希罗多德描述的这个著名的宏大场景，他凝视着远方，然后突然放声大哭，他的叔叔问他，你为什么哭泣？薛西斯说，我看着这一切，所有这些在我指挥下的男人，
and then I suddenly thought that in a hundred years, not one of them will be left alive. Gosh. Well, Xerxes is such an impressive, profound thinker, isn't he? I admire him for that. I mean, he clearly didn't say that, because that's a very greek perspective it's kind of projecting it onto him right i i think that um herodotus does say that you know
然后我突然想到，一百年后，他们当中没有一个人能活下来。天哪。嗯，薛西斯真是一位令人印象深刻、深邃的思想家，不是吗？我很佩服他这一点。我的意思是，他显然没有这么说，因为这是非常希腊式的观点，这是一种投射到他身上的视角，对吧？我认为希罗多德确实说过，你知道
xerxes is the most physically impressive the most um kind of authoritative figure in the army that he deserved to be king so there's a recognition that xerxes is a very kind of impressive but that said Tom so that scene is is Herodotus projecting but then you say Herodotus then says Xerxes is incredibly formidable and impressive and everything but I mean presumably that's Herodotus projecting as well isn't it that's him creating a suitable villain yeah for the Greeks to defeat so actually in a sense we know nothing about Xerxes that's not filtered through all this this sort of historicizing propaganda well I I think the fact that Herodotus obviously the fact you know Xerxes is the great invader uh he loses so it's inevitable that he's going to be cast as the villain I think the fact that Herodotus can say he's also a very impressive figure
薛西斯是军队中最具外表震撼力、最具权威性的人物，他配得上做国王，所以人们承认薛西斯是一个非常令人印象深刻的人，话虽如此，汤姆，所以那个场景是希罗多德的投射，但你又说希罗多德接着说薛西斯极其强大、令人印象深刻等等，但据我推测那也是希罗多德的投射，对吧？那是他为了希腊人去击败而创造的一个合适的反派，所以实际上从某种意义上说，我们对薛西斯的了解没有一个是未经这种历史化宣传过滤的。好吧，我认为希罗多德显然——事实上，你知道，薛西斯是伟大的侵略者，他失败了，所以他不可避免地会被塑造成反派，我认为希罗多德能说他也是一个非常令人印象深刻的人物，这一事实
yeah if he was King John he would not have done that no he would not so i think i think that um we can assume that xerxes is an impressive figure not only because um the you know herodotus says he is but also because he he does actually control this great army yeah he he does hold it all together um and that's no easy feat at all and so they cross the hellespont yeah takes seven days according to herodotus and they start marching along northern greece and then down and the fleet is slowly kind of matching it as it slips along the coastline and so there's this sense of this terrifying force coming towards athens towards Sparta. And this inevitably generates kind of immense panic among the Greeks who have decided that they're going to fight.
是的，如果他是约翰王，他绝对不会这么做，绝对不会。所以我想我们可以假设薛西斯是一个令人印象深刻的人物，不仅因为你知道希罗多德这么说，还因为他确实控制了这支庞大的军队，是的，他确实把这一切维系在了一起，这绝非易事。于是他们渡过了赫勒斯滂，是的，根据希罗多德的说法花了七天时间，他们开始沿着希腊北部行军，然后南下，舰队顺着海岸线滑行，慢慢地与陆军保持同步。因此有一种可怕的力量向雅典、向斯巴达逼近的感觉。
So they do what the Greeks always do in such situations, which is to consult Apollo at Delphi. And so the Spartans send a message. And the message from Apollo is that the only way that Sparta can hold out is if a king of Sparta dies. So that's that's something for the Spartans to think about. And then the Athenians, the Athenians go and the Athenian messengers walk in and the Pythia, this kind of old woman dressed in a young girl's dress, who Apollo speaks through her, goes, whoa, you're screwed. You're absolutely screwed. Is that what she says? Pretty much.
这不可避免地在决定战斗的希腊人中引发了巨大的恐慌。所以他们做了希腊人在这种情况下总会做的事，那就是去德尔斐咨询阿波罗。于是斯巴达人派出了使者。阿波罗传达的信息是，斯巴达能够坚持下去的唯一方法是一名斯巴达国王死去。所以这让斯巴达人陷入了深思。然后雅典人，雅典人去了，雅典的使者走了进去，皮媞亚——这个穿着年轻女孩衣服的老妇人，阿波罗通过她说话——说，哇，你们完蛋了。你们绝对完蛋了。她是这么说的吗？差不多吧。
You're screwed. Run to the ends of the world. You know, you're going to be murdered. And the Athenians totter out and they're kind of pale and they can't believe it. Surely Apollo can give us something to be murdered. And the Athenians totter out and they're kind of pale and they can't believe it. Surely Apollo can give us something to cling to. And this priest comes out and says, guys, give it another go.
你们完蛋了。逃到天涯海角去吧。你知道，你们会被谋杀的。雅典人摇摇晃晃地走出来，脸色苍白，简直不敢相信。难道阿波罗就不能给我们一点可以依附的东西吗？然后这个女祭司走出来说，伙计们，再试一次吧。
Let's see what he comes up with this time. And I'm going to read what Apollo says because it's very important for what then subsequently happened. So Apollo says, Athena has been begging Zeus to spare Athens and Zeus has determined that Athens is going to burn and yet this word I give you adamant a promise everything within the borders of Attica shall fall yes and the sacred veils of nearby mountain ranges but the wooden wall alone the wooden wall shall stand that much zeus grants to athena as an aid to you and all your children men on horses men on foot sweeping they come from asia retreat for soon enough you will meet with them face to
看看他这次会想出什么。我要宣读阿波罗的话，因为这对随后的事情非常重要。所以阿波罗说，雅典娜一直在乞求宙斯饶恕雅典，而宙斯已经决定雅典必将燃烧，然而我给你们这个坚如磐石的承诺：阿提卡境内的一切都将沦陷，是的，附近山脉的神圣面纱也将沦陷，但唯有木墙，木墙将屹立不倒，宙斯将这一点赐予雅典娜，作为对你和你所有孩子的援助。骑马的人，步行的的人，席卷而来，他们从亚洲赶来，撤退吧，因为很快你们将与他们面对面相见。神圣的萨拉米斯，你将成为许多母亲儿子的毁灭之地，当种子被播撒，或当收获被收割时。
face divine salamis you will be the ruin of many a mother's son when the seed is scattered or the harvest is gathered in and so typically delphic message full of kind of riddles and uncertainties messengers go back themistically caesars on it what is the wooden wall there are some who say the wooden wall is the fortifications that surround the acropolis and so so therefore, what Delphi is saying is, you know, hold on to the Acropolis and try and sit the siege out. Themistocles says, no, the wooden wall is our fleet. We should trust to our fleet. That is going to be the wall of Athens.
这是一个典型的德尔斐神谕，充满了谜语和不确定性。使者们回去了，地米斯托克利抓住了重点。什么是木墙？有些人说木墙是环绕卫城周围的防御工事，因此，德尔斐所说的是，你知道，坚守卫城，试着熬过围城。地米斯托克利说，不，木墙就是我们的舰队。我们应该信任我们的舰队。那将是雅典的墙。
We should abandon Attica. We should evacuate it, even though we are sprung from its soil. But we should trust to the wooden wall that is our, this incredible fleet that we've built just in the nick of time and divine salamis what does that mean well salamis is this island just off attica with a very kind of narrow straits between it and what that offers is the possibility of negating the overwhelming force that the persian fleet has because if you can trap them in the straits then their numbers will actually count against them and so Themistocles says this is what we should do we should evacuate Athens we should send our women and children across the sea to Troasin which is a city in the Peloponnese we should evacuate the old men and the gods
我们应该放弃阿提卡。我们应该撤离它，尽管我们是从它的土地上生根发芽的。但我们应该信任木墙，也就是我们刚刚在千钧一发之际建造的这支令人难以置信的舰队，以及神圣的萨拉米斯。那是什么意思？嗯，萨拉米斯是阿提卡附近的一个岛屿，它与大陆之间有非常狭窄的海峡，这提供了这样一种可能性：消灭波斯舰队压倒性的兵力优势，因为如果你能把他们困在海峡里，他们的数量实际上就会成为他们的劣势。因此地米斯托克利说，这就是我们应该做的，我们应该撤离雅典，我们应该把我们的妇女和儿童送到海的那一边、伯罗奔尼撒半岛的一个城市特罗森，我们应该把老人和神像转移到萨拉米斯，我们应该信任舰队。我们还应该在放弃雅典之前，试着守住一条前沿防线。地米斯托克利一直在北方进行侦察任务，他们认识到他们无法守住奥林匹斯山周围的防线，奥林匹斯山你知道就在色萨利附近，但在色萨利以南，有一条非常非常狭窄的道路，一边是大海，另一边是高山悬崖，那里有滚烫的硫磺温泉，所以在希腊语中它被称为热门谷——温泉关，大海——你不仅要守住陆地，你还得守住海洋。优卑亚岛，它的头部一直延伸到靠近温泉关的地方。
statues of the gods to Salamis and we should trust to the fleet we should also before we abandon athens try and hold a forward line and thermistocles has been on kind of reconnoitering mission north they've recognized that they can't hold the kind of um the the line around mount olympus which you know is is uh near thessaly but south of thessaly there is um there's a very very narrow road that has the sea on one side and a mountain pass mount high mountain cliffs on the other uh there are hot boiling springs of sulfur there and so it's called the hot gates thermopylae in greek and the sea that you can't just hold the land, you've also got to hold the sea. There's the island of Euboea, which its head kind of reaches up just next to where Thermopylae is.
那里也有狭窄的海峡。所以如果舰队去那里一个叫阿耳忒密斯昂的海滩——以狩猎女神阿耳忒密斯的庙宇命名，也许部队可以守住关隘，我们的舰队可以守住这个海军等同于关隘的地方，也许我们可以把波斯人阻挡在那里。这就是计划，他们等待着，等待着，但波斯人仍然没有来。八月到了，我们记得谈论过我们做过的奥运会那一集。我们以此开局，奥运会是如何开始的，斯巴达人非常清楚他们对众神的义务。在奥运会期间，他们不能打仗。
And there are kind of narrow straits there as well. So if the fleet goes there to a beach called Artemisian, named after a temple to Artemis, the goddess of the hunt, maybe the troops can hold the pass and our fleet can hold this you know naval equipment this maritime equivalent of a pass and maybe we can we can keep the persians at bay there and this is the plan and they wait and they wait but still the persians don't come and august comes and we remember talking about the um the olympic episode that we did. We opened with this, how the Olympic Games start and the Spartans are very kind of aware of their obligations to the gods. They can't fight during the Olympics, the Olympic festival.
但随后消息传来，波斯人已经兵临城下。于是斯巴达人决定派遣列奥尼达率领300人前往，这300人全都有了孩子，言下之意是他们知道会有巨大的死亡风险，而且当然还有来自阿波罗的预言，即只有斯巴达国王的死才能让斯巴达生存下去。斯巴达人向北挺进。他们在路上集结了大约5000人。其中包括来自底比斯的人，底比斯分为反对波斯的人和支持波斯的人。因此，那些想要反对波斯的人跟随列奥尼达和其他人一起，他们抵达了关隘。与此同时，希腊舰队向北航行到阿耳忒密斯昂，它不由地米斯托克利指挥，因为
But then the news comes, the Persians are almost at the gates. So the Spartans decide to send Leonidas with 300 men all of whom have already had children so the implication is they know that you know there's a massive risk that they're going to die and there is of course also that prophecy from from Apollo that only the death of a Spartan king will enable Sparta to survive the Spartansans advance northwards. They accumulate about 5,000 men on the way. Among them, men from Thebes, which is divided between people who want to oppose the Persians and to side with the Persians. So those who want to oppose the Persians go with lenidas and his and the other men they arrive at the gates meanwhile the the greek fleet sails northwards to artemisian um it's not under the command of themistocles because
其他所有人都讨厌雅典人，他们都嫉妒雅典人拥有这支新舰队，科林斯人、墨加拉人和埃伊纳人等等都是如此。所以他们实际上是在一个斯巴达海军上将的指挥下服役，但实际上是由地米斯托克利指挥。所以你有了陆地上的列奥尼达，你有了随时准备出海的地米斯托克利。哦，那种紧张感，汤姆，那种紧张感！然后，然后——在远处可以看到淡淡的尘雾升起，黎明时分，从阿耳忒密斯昂正北方的斯基亚托斯岛射出一道闪光，发出信号，表明人们已经看到了第一批波斯船只。
everybody else hates the athenians they're all jealous of them for having this new fleet the corinthians and the megarans and the people from aegina people like that so they're actually serving under a spartan admiral but effectively themistocles is in command so you've got Laenidas on land you've got Themistocles ready at sea oh the tension Tom the tension and then and then haze a distant dust haze is seen rising in the distance and a flash of light comes from the island of Skiathos, which is just north of Artemisian, at dawn, signalling that the first Persian ships have been seen.
太棒了。好吧，这为下一集做好了极好的铺垫。所以我原本以为这一集是关于温泉关的。但没有，它是关于通往温泉关之路的。气氛再凝重不过了。空气中弥漫着电流，甚至当我坐在这里的时候。空气中确实弥漫着电流。
Brilliant. Well, that sets things up very nicely for the next episode. So I thought this episode was going to be about Thermopylae. But no, it's about the road to Thermopylae. The atmosphere could not be more heavy. There's electricity in the air, even as I'm sitting here. There literally is electricity in the air.
我将在下一集开始时解释原因。天哪，多么诱人的前景啊。所以请收看下一集的《历史的剩余》，届时温泉关之战终于要打响了，我们到时候见。再见。感谢收听《历史的剩余》。如需收听额外单集、提前收听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。
And I will explain why at the beginning of the next episode. God, what a tantalising prospect. So tune in next time to the next episode of The Rest Is History when finally the Battle of Thermopylae will get underway and we will see you then. Goodbye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我将在下一集的开头解释原因。天哪，多么诱人的前景啊。所以请收看下一期《历史就是这样》，届时温泉关战役终于要开始了，我们到时见。再见。感谢收听《历史就是这样》。想要收听独家节目、提前听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请访问 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。